in this video i'm going to be exploring
a potential thrust missing aikido now i
realize this might divide opinions
however i thought it'd be a good topic
to discuss so please bear with me to the
end of the video so you hear out my
thought process anyway with that being
said let's get into it
[Music]
so when we talk about thrusting there
could be so many different variables
we can be thrusting behind at different
angles or utilizing the length of the
joe similar to how you might see in
other martial arts however that's not
what we're talking about in this video
regardless of aikido style there are
only three hand placements that are
utilized for a thrust
so to understand what the potential
fourth option is we first need to look
at the existing three
the first is the most common type of
thrust with both thumbs pointing towards
the thrusting end
whether it's low middle
or high the same rule applies
these thrusts tend to be most common and
transition easily into strikes given
hand positioning the second type is
typically a high thrust with both thumbs
pointing away from the thrusting end
this thrust can also be done behind and
transition easily into the first thrust
i showed you previously
the third type is practice where both
thumbs are pointing inwards
due to the symmetry of the grip this
thrust transitions easily from side to
side and front to back
it is however one of the least used to
us
and that's probably down to less options
to transition into all the movements
so this leads us to the fourth potential
type of thrust
we've looked at thumbs pointing forwards
we've looked at thumbs pointing
backwards
and we've also looked at thumbs pointing
inwards
however we haven't looked at thumbs
pointing outwards now i know some of you
will be thinking that looks awkward how
can you possibly thrust from there well
if you take the front hand
and utilize it in the same sort of way
as the first bus and you take the
backhand and use it in the same sort of
way as the second thrust
you end up
with a thrust
that could potentially work
some of you might be thinking well is
this viable can it transition into all
the movements well i'll address that in
the next video
until then i want to hear your thoughts
do you think this has got any potential
and is there any specific reasons why it
shouldn't be practiced
let me know in the comments
anyway until then
take care and i'll see you soon